he always said that he'd be back but is
it time for the Terminator to terminate
his action career this stuntman snafu
might make it seem like a good idea
Arnold Schwarzenegger is back in action
and Netflix is Fubar a Twist on the
concept of his movie True Lies the eight
episode series sees Arnie in the role of
a grouchy dad and longtime CIA agent
looking out for his daughter Emma boomi
discovers also works for the agency
while some fans are happy to see more of
their favorite action star there's one
recurring issue that the actor can't
avoid in a small screen Soiree as much
of an icon as Schwarzenegger is it's
clear that age is becoming an issue for
him and it's never more apparent than in
the series's opening scene the beginning
of the first episode sees Arnie's Luke
Bruner leaping into action on an
infiltration Mission using a fire truck
as covered a sneak past security the
issue is that it's glaringly apparent
that Schwarzenegger isn't really who
we're looking at and that it's someone
else doing tuck and roll stunts and
jumping off of fire engines it makes for
a pretty poor first impression raising
questions about later scenes where
Arnold is or isn't called into action
I'm busy anyway so give this job to my
friend here he loves playing in the
jungle
from hopping between cars and high-speed
car chases to jumping out of planes it's
clear that some of the biggest action
scenes in Fubar don't involve the series
star with that in mind it might be time
for Arnold Schwarzenegger to take
himself out of the action pack to be old
and get into some more restrained roles
is a path that's been taken by other
action stars of Zara think of Kurt
Russell and fate of the Furious or
Sylvester Stallone and Guardians of the
Galaxy Vol 3. they're still in the game
in action-packed movies but calling the
shots from the sidelines while the other
Heroes get in on the action for the most
part in pubar Schwarzenegger doesn't get
too involved in the fight scenes but
when he does it's usually a little more
Awkward than the creators may have
intended we're not saying hasta la vista
to Schwarzenegger but it might be better
for everyone if he takes it easy in his
next role while pubar doesn't feature
Arnold Schwarzenegger at his physical
peak it's still exciting to see the
action Superstar take on a brand new
role over five decades into his career
in recent interviews the superstars
shared that he knows it's time to evolve
and chart A New Path as a performer as
part of that you can say goodbye to the
chance of any future appearance as one
of his most famous roles during his
press rounds for Fubar the actor
candidly told The Hollywood Reporter
that it was time to call it curtains on
the Terminator franchise the series that
made him a pop culture of sensation
discussing the reaction to the series
most recent movie he said of his
involvement I'm done I got the message
loud and clear that the world wants to
move on with a different theme when it
comes to the Terminator someone has to
come up with a great idea
I had a retirement plan
is Schwarzenegger who has played the
T800 on and off since the 80s is ready
to retire from his most iconic role
what's next Arnie made headlines
recently when he joined Netflix the
streaming service behind Fubar as its
Chief action officer in a marketing
video while it might be best for the
actor to become a mentor for the next
generation of action Mavericks
Schwarzenegger has no plans to take it
easy he told thr I still work out every
day I ride my bike every day and I make
movies my plan is to live forever and so
far so good
foreign
[Music]